هنا على حدود قطاع غزه تاهب امني اسرائيلي
لا تخطئه العين انتشار لبطاريات القبه
الحديديه في اكثر من موقع بسبب خشيه
اسرائيل من استمرار التصعيد بعد اطلاق
صواريخ عده من القطاع وبعد اتهام حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي والفصائل الفلسطينيه
لاسرائيل باغتيال القياده في الجهاد الشيخ
خضر عدنان الذي نفذ اضرابا طويلا على
الطعام في السجون الاسرائيليه
والخشيه الاسرائيليه الاخرى هي مما قد
يحدث داخل السجون
الاسرائيليه من احتجاجات ومواجهات مع
الاسرى الفلسطينيين هناك بالاضافه الى
جبهات اخرى
وفي العلاقه الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه
المتفجره بطبيعتها تخشى اسرائيل من
المعادله السائده مؤخرا التي تسمى وحده
الساحات او الجبهات بحيث يمتد التصعيد من
السجون الاسرائيليه الى قطاع غزه وصولا
الى ضفه الغربيه المحتله وانتهاء ربما حتى
بالحدود الشماليه مع سوريا ولبنان كما حدث
من قبل ولهذا فان التاهب بات سائدا على
جميع هذه الجبهات زياد حلبي العربيه حدود
قطاع غزه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات